what places are not getting stronger New
York Cali Michigan masks there are kids
in schools in masks in Ann Arbor
Michigan right now but Republicans are
getting a backbone like a ramrod and how
are they doing it well because of a
blueprint
and where did that blueprint start it
started right here in the Free State of
Florida because one guy said no no no no
I don't like you fouchy and we ain't
turning this place into fauciville
here's the Ron DeSantis yesterday
Florida over the last couple years I
mean it's just crazy the number of
people that are down here at any given
time of course people moving here but
also visiting here and we were really I
mean by far when you start talking about
like 2020 2021 I mean we were number one
destination by far and so that has
helped uh really fill our coffers and
we're even in most recent month I think
we were uh 450 million dollars higher in
Revenue than than was anticipated and so
you know those are things as you budget
that's money coming in you know not
because there's taxes are changing it's
just because there's more economic
activity uh and the economy is growing
and so that would not have been possible
you know if we had turned Florida into a
fauciville it would not have been
possible and so we had to make sure to
do the right thing yeah you do the right
thing and next thing you know you've got
governors in Iowa that are doing the
right thing governors in Arkansas that
are doing the right thing and then they
just start realizing boy I'm not the
only one that has to step up I think
part of what's going on here and that's
why I always talk about it at a
spiritual level it's like people are
afraid of being the guy who steps up and
and by the way being the guy who steps
up not only is it not easy it doesn't
always end well I guess in probably most
cases it doesn't end well to be the guy
who really says to the system no right
the buck stops with me I will not
participate in the lie anymore
but now he's done it and now we're
seeing it exported
[Music]